generalicemos lo que hemos estado
haciendo en los últimos vídeos para
calcular el retorno real y así quizás
nos encontremos con algunas fórmulas
interesantes bueno lo que hemos estado
haciendo o al menos en el primer vídeo
es convertirnos todo a dinero de hoy así
que el retorno actual en dólares de hoy
es la cantidad que obtuvimos es decir el
dólar neto el retorno en dólar neto y el
retorno en dólar neto es la cantidad que
originalmente invertimos agravado por la
tasa de interés nominal estamos
asumiendo que lo estamos escribiendo en
forma decimal así que en este ejemplo
que hemos estado usando fue del 10%
entonces esto va a ser de 0.10 en total
el valor va a ser de 1 punto 10 y esto
es lo que vamos a obtener después de
pasado un año entonces en nuestro
ejemplo esto fue de 110 dólares 100
dólares agravados por 1.1 y de aquí lo
que queremos es restar lo que invertimos
en el dinero actual invertimos p dólares
hace un año y para el dinero actual
multiplicamos por la tasa de inflación
en los ejemplos asumimos que la tasa de
inflación es de 2 por ciento entonces
pongo 0.02 muy bien esta expresión de
aquí ese retorno en dólares con dinero
actual es este valor aquí estos 8
dólares lo calculamos en el primer vídeo
y para calcular el retorno real queremos
el retorno en dólar con dinero actual
dividido por la inversión en dinero
actual y ahora nuevamente esta es la
inversión en dinero actual es la
inversión original que hicimos aumentada
por la inflación entonces toda esta
fórmula nos da el retorno real lo pongo
como r ahora algo que podemos hacer para
simplificar todo esto es observar que
tenemos todo en el numerador y todo en
el denominador todo esto es divisible
por p entonces hagamos lo vamos a
dividir por el numerador y el
denominador y así simplificamos un poco
y ahora que sigue a bueno en el
numerador vamos a tener lo siguiente 1 +
n menos uno más y lo pongo de esta
manera y el numerador va a estar sobre
uno más
toda esta expresión va a ser igual a r y
estoy aquí dando espacio porque una
simplificación que puedo hacer aquí
puedo sumar uno a ambos lados de la
ecuación entonces sumó uno aquí del lado
derecho y debo sumar uno del lado
izquierdo pero uno es igual que uno más
y sobre uno más y esto es igual a uno
entonces está quedando igual son
completamente equivalentes a estas dos
expresiones así que estamos sumando uno
del lado izquierdo y uno del lado
derecho y la razón por la que hice esto
es porque nos va a dar unas interesantes
simplificación ajá mira tenemos el mismo
denominador aquí uno más y si sumamos
los numeradores tenemos uno más y más
uno más en el menos uno más y los uno
más si se cancelan y tenemos en el
numerador uno más la tasa de interés
nominal y en el denominador vamos a
tener uno más la tasa de inflación uno
más la tasa de inflación es igual a uno
más la tasa de interés real y ahora qué
pasa a bueno lo que sucede es que
multiplicamos ambos lados por el uno más
y lo hacemos multiplicamos ambos lados
uno y de este lado uno más y del otro
lado y nos va a quedar un resultado
bastante interesante aunque a tal grado
tal vez esto este resultado sea sentido
común y ahora observa todo es
consistente estos dos cuatros se
cancelan y obtenemos cuando componemos
por la tasa de interés nominal es igual
es igual al aumento del crecimiento y
eso compuesto por la tasa de inflación